anh alo
ờ ờ ờ
Xin chào bạn
bên ngoài mình à
ở ngoài mình nhà mình hiện tại đang khá
ổn
chị đã các bạn không ai thấy gì đâu đúng
à Bố mày thì các bạn thấy là tiêu đề nó
sẽ là hôm nay mình làm tận phần 3 rồi
bình thường ở tính năng này kiểu tính
năng bồi thêm thôi đừng ngại phải kiểu
xử lý trong hết một ngày
cho cháu hỏi một buổi mình sang tận buổi
thứ ba rồi nhưng mà chắc là cũng cung
cấp cho các bạn khá nhiều thông tin hoặc
Ok thì bây giờ đầu tiên mình cứ tạo link
để các bạn thể xem nhá Hôm nay mình sẽ
thử cố để mà dậy à cho xong dứt điểm cái
thêm cả sửa và xóa Thằng này thì sẽ như
thế nào ạ
tâm sự cả
ừ ừ
bộ trang phục ngắn hỏi mấy ông để người
ông Tý trả lời xe mà
hôm qua mùng 1 tháng 6 mấy ông đã làm
những gì à
Ê mày cái này thì mình trả lời dần dần
dần sau này
Xin
chào bạn phạm thời đại khái thế
à à lẫn ạ một tí nữa đó là mình mấy ông
Nếu ông xem cái tài liệu bên này thì tôi
thường hay Liệt kê những cái mà tôi đã
dạy đã dậy xong sẽ ở bên này là những
cái mà sắt dậy hoặc cái cái dưới này à
Tôi đang tìm hiểu tôi sẽ dậy sau còn
những tài ở trên này tôi sẽ dậy dần dần
mấy ông chẳng hạn đấy và những cái này
đã dậy xong này đây thì mày ông hoàn
toàn để xem về mà có gì thì thì biết
được vào tôi đã dạy con những cái gì thì
xem tổng hợp lại các thứ cúng
à à
trước và mình giờ xử mình muốn thêm một
cái bà đang mới đúng ạ thì mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ cậu tiền nhập nhập kiểu
Company có thiếu tớ đó ngoại Company sau
đó thì à
thì nó sẽ kiểu tự động Zura ja Thái Tổ
thread kiểu như này không ạ Mình có thể
chọn nhiều ngôn ngữ nó sẽ hiểu ra ra chỗ
như này rồi chọn City - chút xong rồi có
thể Điền min max số gì gì đó như thế này
không ạ Rồi mình sẽ kiểm tra điều kiện
các thứ thứ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ dần dần
mình làm điều này nhá Ừ
à à
hỗ trợ miễn phí
bắt buộc điên này
ừ ừ
Ở nhà chẳng hạn ông ạ Đây số chẳng hạn ở
chất và mình sẽ
á Đối với Vinamilk được ra mình không
cần làm Varus nhớ là đổi bên khách hàng
thì mấy cái này à không phải biết khách
hàng mà chính bên khác rồi là sử dụng ấy
thì sẽ phải vài đoạn này nên thế thì ông
mới ông làm bếp dạo này cũng được
Vì
vậy các bạn để tôi thấy giao diện của
thằng thằng ngày với bên hàng HR nó đang
khá là giống nhau khá là giống nhau về
sau chắc như thế tôi cứ làm virus luôn
cả đoạn này cho mấy ông sẽ hình dung nhé
đây trong trường hợp khi thêm này nó bạn
mình sẽ tạo một cái là iMac này
máy quét mã
à à
và Store with a
Tính thời sự
ninh có còn gần như là mấy cái Index này
crash này và Store Index thì chắc là
mình sẽ kiểm tra thêm quyền nữa
có quyền người Dung ở
Anh ở trước mắt thì mình cứ làm ở bên
admin sau đó thì về sau mình tuyển dụng
Thế à mình tôi đang định làm sẽ ưu tiên
là làm ở Việt Nam Min trước sau đó nhỉ
Sang bên
kiểu cho kiểu cho các ứng cử viên tất cả
cho mấy ông ấy làm cho mấy ông à Mấy ông
có thể vào để mà xem được những cái bài
đăng tuyển dụng nhưng hai kết hợp việc
là tìm kiếm những câu cơ hội việc làm
cho bản thân mình sau đó nữa là mấy ông
vẫn có thể đăng nhập để mà đăng cái CV
mấy ông lên kèm theo là kiểu là kiểu có
cậu open open forward có cho phép và ạ
nhạc
Ừ ừ thực à nếu thêm một cái cột Open
World được vẽ để cho kiểu khr với vào
sen nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà đại khái thì gần nhà sẽ đăng
lên một cái CV để mày ông có thể để cho
các h&r có thể xem thôi
Ừ chắc là đang lên đây là kiểu gì mà yêu
của Open forward rồi tại Khánh Như Thế ạ
sau đó thì HR mới mới tôi 15h ở sau cùng
hát rồi Chỉ cần lên đây mà đăng bài về
sau tôi không cần tự đăng nữa Chả thế
ạ
bây giờ đầu tiên à Story quét không ạ
một tí đó là nếu mà giả sử đặt tên kiểu
này chung quá nhiều lúc mà nó gợi ý ra
kèm như này gọi ý rồi nha cho về sau bị
nhiều quá rồi nó
cái này nó bé quái chẳng hạn hãy gì đó
mấy ông hoặc là nó không gợi ý đủ ra đấy
cũng hơi khó hơi có sự nhưng mà vẫn
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
ô tô request lúc đầu mặc định là cứ cho
là Chu đi chưa làm về vụ lau nhỉ Chắc
phải làm dần dần vụ đau
ở đây sẽ là đây này à
thì mình sẽ có mà
Ừ trước hết thì tôi cứ mặc định à
toilet ơn trả về kết quả toàn bộ này đã
ẩn Glass đây này nếu không sẽ thấy ra là
mình sẽ truyền lên là Company ngoặc
Company
rồi anh sẽ Company này
những gì bắt buộc phải điên nhá Ừ
a many để trống
buộc phải điền ông nhỉ Xem lại Pháp
em biết
Company g đây nhớ không bắt buộc phải
điền thì ông sẽ làm được tia sinh này và
new label là được phép vi sóng này à
thế
này
tiếp theo ở
ừ ừ
a language đối ngoại năm which
số trang web vừa phải điền và
anh ở đây Ông thấy là 46 bây giờ xử tôi
chọn nhiều lo web thì sao
bị này rồi à
ý nghĩa sao lỗi đấy bị này rồi Tại sao
ra 46 chọn rất nhiều lông quý phải trả
giá 46 bởi vì à nếu mà ông không có
không chỉnh cái hàng này thằng language
này nó làm mạnh thì nó sẽ chỉ có lừa
đúng một giá trị thôi ông sẽ phải để nó
làm ảnh hưởng như này đấy Lúc về ông mới
chọn được nhiều nhé
chọn lại nha
thế này này
những ngày
này ngon
ừ ừ
đúng ạ nhưng mà bây giờ nó không nó đang
không
u&i nào lỗi này em để em không thấy thôi
Thế giờ mày làm như thế nào Bây giờ thì
thực tế thực tế là tối không muốn điều
hướng trang để một quay trở lại như thế
Tôi muốn à mình sẽ dùng Asus bọn này để
mà mình sẽ
mình sắc nhọn này để mở kiểu thì chị ra
được luôn Kết quả là thành công hay thất
bại thì tôi sẽ dùng thêm một thư viện
nữa ở thư viện address for iPhone thì nó
sẽ
thì nó sẽ là cậu ở sắp ít toàn bộ cái
pho mày lên hội cho mấy ông và tôi sẽ
dùng luôn cả fanpage
để mà cậu sắp được cái form
làm thủ công với cái này
Ừ để xem nha Gặp Phone
thư viện đấy rồi thế thư viện đấy nó chả
có gì cả nhưng mà này
mình sẽ cài thư viện đoạn này đi làm thì
a free from
cho iPhone 5
ừ ừ
a trai nó kiểu chị Dạo này thôi
sẽ dùng cái đơn giản đi ngờ trước hết
mình à
Ừ ừ là sử Mấy ông không dùng dị ra quét
virus thì mày Ông không cần phải thêm
cái ra Speed vip Viettel nhưng tôi cứ
ngồi quay cho bé uống xe
ý của mình
tôi miễn phí
ừ ừ
à à
à
Tôi đang chỉ cho bé uống thêm vài cái
thư viện nữa là Nếu để tham khảo thư
viện là thư viện là Duy và về biết này
đúng không ạ
thể dùng CD no
làm nhanh đi
Linh
để tui quay gj
ừ ừ
ạ sau đó thì ở đây mình có cái from mình
sẽ tạo vài đứa cho nó
costly mình sẽ rất dài mình sẽ có một
cái form ở đây đặt tên pho mai đi Ở đây
Ford cho này
thế này
nhưng cái trường Du ở đây sẽ làm cái này
cái cái này nó sẽ làm nêm của từng gái
đây này dụng nên thằng này là cục cân đi
đúng không ạ
bắt buộc phải điên này hãy chẳng hạn thế
Chúng tôi sẽ sửa lại đây như này
Ừ
bắt buộc phải Điền Nha và ông có thể là
em xem cái lu của nó để nó có gồm những
cái gì
lu này
ở đâu có dù ở đây có những cái Dung như
thế nào
anh không được nhắn quá này không ạ sau
khi mạch in ra thông báo nó sẽ in ra cái
gì chẳng hạn thế
a nhớ Du này có nhiều lắm Tự nhiên ở đây
nó bị trong thời nó đơn giản quá
thể nói chung là thư viện này tại địa
của tôi đang thấy nó bị Hơi bị chán đỡ
tí nhớ Trang này nó không cấp như thường
xuyên đây này Chồng nói chán xem thử nó
hát chồng cũng đỡ hơn không
Ừ ừ Download này pallet biết ai đâu mà
dai không bỏ qua
thư viện này nó ngon nhưng mà quan trọng
là nó kiểu
viết tài liệu nó đang bị sơ sài quá mặc
cảm mình mùi mò Nó hơi bất công không
cô giáo phải ngồi mò cái bạn ấy
điểm là nó có cả quý khách các thứ
khi sex
những video như trông chán nhỉ
rồi
à à
chỗ còn equato là cho bằng xe nào này
Cách Cách tập thứ thế này cơ kệ Đã thế
thôi thử test trong khi ông xem nhé
Có ai đang trắng tinh đúng không nút nút
này nó không bấm không ạ
tôi Giả sử với cho mặc định núi này bấm
được đi sẽ ở đây là ra xử cho định nút
bấm được đi
có gì ạ khi mình bấm ấn sắp ít đây này
Có mấy ông thầy nói chuyện lên mặc định
nó sẽ truyền lên như nào đó sẽ cái này
là không mua đỏ
Hero ngoài đăng không phải mặc định màu
đỏ sẽ cho thêm Style chưa này đi mình sẽ
Style này Đây là class Hero này thì sẽ
ra cola cho ạ
à à
anh Siro
anh vẫn không phải gọi không được
anh hỏi rõ ràng classr Alo mày nghỉ à
ừ ừ
à à
ở Myanmar tuần em ạ ạ
a class Hero ID
[âm nhạc]
a slit Company Euro
ở đâu mà nghỉ
ừ ừ
a-class pro
a good CF Tôi nghĩ là cái xếp hình như
Biết sai ở đoạn là cái ảo Mình chưa cho
truyền CF lên trên thì à
Ừ vậy đi chuột máy nào này Master này
tách ra Swift
à À đấy bảo sao sẽ phải có Spec xé rồi
đây sau đó 10 phút lên đây nhược điểm đó
là đó là bây giờ mình không có sách này
tồn tại nhưng mà nó không thì bảo lỗi
thì đã
không chọn này ok ok rồi đó nghĩa là cái
thư viện cái thư viện này
bí thư viện à ngày nó sẽ ra hết hộ mấy
ông về vết hộ là kiểu đấy thậm chưa vào
đây hộp mail hay ghi rách cao thử thử
rất là tiện
ở nhà riêng nó và đến một cái tương đối
thôi mày Không Thể Và thậm chí 25 ít
luôn ở đây trong mấy ông này bắt buộc
phải điên Cái gì đó Ừ
cách soi lô
ở xít-ni natalya
Tab tất cả mà cái đoạn này đi ờ ờ
vừa nãy tôi nhớ là khi mà thành công thì
sẽ ạ
bộ phim thành công thì nó sẽ có liên
quan hệ ảo giác gì vậy Ở đây toàn bộ
lisp iWin đây
a Mimax da này
bằng với thằng nào này tôi thích thì đôi
khi mình dùng cái gạch ra ngon
uruk a giờ cái đoạn sắp ít hơn đồ này
khi mà kiểu khi mà kiểu xử lý xong hết
mình sẽ xử lý đây mình sẽ
hài đi thì mới ông sẽ xem là
Chị xem điều gì xảy ra khi tải lại trang
xong rồi tôi điên điên Cái này là sử tôi
có đi đúng không ấn vào này đây iPhone
không được xem ít nó sẽ mặc định là nát
không cho mình sắp ít rồi này
em không cho mình sẽ biết ở đây và mình
hoàn toàn sẽ dùng nhá rác ở đây mà sao
mít a giác thì mình sẽ có buổi trưa này
thôi thì sẽ có một đoạn AB ở đây này
Xiaomi cái pho mình lên để mình sẽ sắp
ít bằng hoặc lá rách chứ không phải là
chứ không phải là kiểu
Ê mày chửi quay quay trở lại vân vân nữa
ừ ừ
với toàn bộ thông tin của nó là Siri
like
thế nhưng ai lấy toàn bộ tin trong form
Này đẩy lên này ăn mì ở đây tôi sẽ gọi
đến store Nhung thương router Store vụ
tai nạn amin này
chấm chấm to này
em
không nhớ lấy được format lấy được form
Action đỡ mất công làm loạn này sang
four này à
ăn trộm abell
viết kiểu này
kiểu Nga như này hay kiểu phải như thế
này nữa chắc kiểu ngày xuân hơn ạ
thêm Đô la ở trong như này em mới thớt
là từ Nhưng mấy teleport thì sẽ trả về
cái quạt trong trường hợp mà
sự thành công và thất bại thì sẽ ra Làm
thế nào đây mình sẽ có Zalo không ạ Có
phí Đây này Nếu có ai rồi sẽ như thế nào
ạ
à à
chị sẽ có solo chấm dog cài Vinaphone
lúc này Alo trước lịch sử là sử ở mình
cứ mặc định là
sai trước đi sai trước đi mình sẽ làm
nha
Ở lại Sang Nga
ở đây à
I speak
Bình Điền
tiếp nè
đúng giờ xử tôi trả về sai sao ạ
nhá đây tôi language từ bắt buộc à
anh về đây bắt buộc nhảy dây này và gửi
qua phần bắt buộc phải điện trở lại
à Dạ
khu du lịch ngay là bắt buộc phải biến
đổi chẳng hạn
Ừ thì
thì bây giờ chắc chắn nó sẽ trở về sai
thì mình sẽ làm nha Bọn phân nữa này Đấy
nó báo lỗi chẳng phải sai cũng theo ông
là Euro Miss là như nào đây cái đâu có
gì đấy ông ạ thì mình sẽ cần bắt cá alo
đấy
Ừ thì đây mấy ông thấy à Có cái á
sporza này mình sẽ gọi hàng VIP or
reason cho gọi đến thằng Alo ạ
A Beat sport
gọi đến Euro như thế này
Ừ rồi xuống nhiều và
cái này nó sẽ làm mà nếu không thấy nó
là mà không ạ Và đây là từng cái nêm 1
từng cái D1 mà mình cần làm ở đây là
mình sẽ in ra tất cả cái lỗi
tôi thường ấy Tôi thường sẽ là sẽ bắt
theo từng thằng in a từng hàng lỗi in ra
vào ở trong một cái kiểu
à à
đoạn này thì nên làm như anh ạ Mình sẽ
in ra lỗi thường là in ra ở phường nào
in ra ở một là trên cùng như thế này còn
với
anh có thể trên cùng ngại được xong nói
lời Y Na
ừ ừ
khi được thế sao đơn giản nhé thì đơn
giản
nghĩ em mình sẽ có một cái
ở đây bạn chất là cái naiwa trên đấy à
ở trên công nữa nhá Ừ tôi sẽ có một cái
a bit nô video content Ở Đây Rồi rau bếp
hay thô
thô của mình nằm ở đây này một cái đít ở
bên trong này
Ừ Ok Thế kịch les này
bộ phim sẽ có một tí hết đâu Ở đây
Ừ Rồi
mình sẽ có một cái đít ở đây là
Có ai đi là
anh đi alo
cho nó
Ừ lát class Euro thì mới ông thể tham
khảo là bút chép ba
Euro chẳng
vì nó có cái à Ở nơi 100 Plus cái cái
kiểu in ra trong một cái đít kiểu nha
này thì sẽ là Plus Đinh Châu ở đây này
Nó đứng đầu đưa như chả có cái gì đấy cả
nó chấm nhưng mà khi mà bây giờ có bất
kỳ có giá trị gì ở đây này bất kỳ có cái
gì ở đây thì mình sẽ là
đúng không Và tôi con của nó nữa chị sẽ
là nói chuyện với tay
à à
ừ ừ
mọi người Tôi là con đấy mình lại phuacs
mà phát nữa đấy mình vẫn phải phó cũng
phát nữa
ở đây sẽ là cá rô này
à à
I eat
ba lô chấm
Béo nhớ cái đoạn là mình sẽ chèn thêm dữ
liệu vào thì tôi nhớ là có cái bộ khen
nhé
anh em
Vì trước hôm trước mình làm gỗ vani ăn
Min này tốt này đất này
thì mình sẽ làm Open Kiều chợ này
ở đầu tiên mình sẽ phải Open URL ở đây
trước
đây là Open URL đây này
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ tên ở đây là lỗi
này trong ly đấy bạn chất ở trong đời
đến mình sẽ tem một cái gì cho nữa
Em đi đi
anh nói gì này
ở đây này
khi chạy thử mày không xem nhé lại trang
này
ừ ừ
xe buýt này lúc đầu thì lúc đầu nó lên
là trống nó lên à
a-class là hai đi mà
hard đ
anh nói gì nhỉ
- 5
chị xem nhé
có người đang bị lỗi lỗi ở dòng cuối là
sao
có giống cây rau đắng
chưa điền với gì đó
Em bấm vào này
ở siêu bắt buộc phải điền này chọn một
cái này anh ấn vào này
Euro ở đây ở đây nó là
anh không nó sẽ kiểu Không in ra không
thì ra thôi
bí ẩn do này
á nhon language có ra ngoài này
nó là optic này nó là ông trách thì là
không phối được à
Vì Sao Thế mình lại chơi trò hôm trước
mình làm ở là
ngay đây là hàm của thằng à
a disease một là mấy ông làm theo cậu là
dùng Siri làm hay là về xong nếu mấy ông
làm được với ra sweet sweet nhiều thì
mới ông biết được là đối tượng để mà
duyệt đối tượng kiểu như này thì mấy ông
sẽ phải à Chơi cậu ngay là Oh jak từ đây
ra switch
mã số gọi đến lấy hàng moshulu như thế
này Đấy chỉ là ông muốn lấy value Còn
nếu mà ông muốn lấy cả và Lu và cả cái
chi đây cái chi nhé Thì ông sẽ dùng hàng
khác hợp âm Chỉ một Lấy kiểu bạn dùng
hàng khác nữa
Zalo sao gọi đến phối kiểu ngay à
em không đi ra gì
á nhon đồi quên quên quên tôi chưa làm
mà in ra để xem trong đít Euro mình có
gì rồi nhé nó ra rồi này Đây đang bị là
Ken ở đây đang vị Cố Vấn đề ở đây là
Open Đúng rồi ở đây Open kiểu ngày nó
Open về Alo trước tôi sẽ Japan kiểu như
này sau đó thì fn-fal cô ấy sẽ đóng
Google Thế xong
ờ ờ
Xỏ cái đít Euro này mình sẽ là sâu thì
sẽ gọi à hàm châu để hiển thị nó ra như
này
anh nghe trong trường hợp mà có alo nhé
Còn không thì ông sẽ và ẩn nó đi Đấy
tại lại trai
xin lỗi mà có lỗi mà không
à à
nó tầng nó ghi để mất rồi
để xem
a Google này vẫn bị dính á
không ở đây Mày không thấy nó bị nhược
điểm là nếu mà ẩn ba lần mà tạo làm ba
cái không ạ ạ
Ừ ông Google này nó sớm quá trước khi cả
đầu đi chạy song với Rõ ràng cái vòng
lọc này chạy này không có tâm hả chạy
sau nhé vẫn vẫn sẽ chạy như này thành ra
là nó bị nó bị sai nó hiểu ý
Ừ để chắc chắn nó béo ông chạy mấy ông
chạy à
cả ngày thường là sao
ở trường đoạn này nó sẽ làm như này Đầu
tiên là đoạn này tôi sẽ có mặc định ở
dùng ra Speed với ẩn hài đi Thôi dùng ra
xếp để hiển thị thằng này lên một cách
hoặc cả xóa cái
ừ ừ
anh xóa size của thằng này đi cũng được
cũng rất nhiều cách để làm người ấy chạy
xe mà ở
gj
sau tin anh à
Ừ rồi à
hai mẫu lồ này nó chạy xử trước
nhà mình có thể bắt gặp kiểu là bắt hơn
hưởng là tôi sẽ bắt kiểu Index là kiểu
dưới nách bằng bằng không thì tôi sẽ cho
Open thêm cái đoạn này
Ừ
tôi sẽ thường có số lóc trong bể không
xem à
anh em vẫn in ra chị nhỉ
Ừ cái này sai rồi bởi vì rõ ràng mà nó
mỗi lỗi gì nó làm về qua dầu nó xài mà
bản chất không ạ thì ở mình mình cần làm
ở đây đó là
ờ ờ
anh với Index bằng không thì mình sẽ
ít Hack bằng bằng không thì mình sẽ chèn
thêm cái Google như này
các bạn này tôi đang làm rất là nông dân
luôn thường là thứ ra chẳng ai làm kiểu
ngay đâu
A và
ạ sau đó thì cuối cùng mình đóng ý thì
cái để mình đóng thì nó lại là khi mà
hình ảnh mới thấy Đợi tôi tí đợi đi
Ô cái con mạng đúng không em đi sẽ có
một mạng ngay
à à
ở đây sẽ chỉ cần alo ngay thôi
ờ ờ
thế hả Google Sonic Fortuner euroland
ý Miêu Lam ngay sau đỏ cái gì nếu mà cái
này đến cái ngưỡng của allow - 1 mà bắt
đầu từ không phải chửi 10 ạ Cho mình sẽ
chèn thêm cái đoạn này nữa nghe xong
vợ chồng nông dân
biết làm nào
sau này có bị dính vào trường hợp thành
phối ngày chưa kịp chạy xong đã nhảy
xuống ngay rồi chèn thêm cái Google
trước không nhỉ
Ẩm Thực ra nhà sợ đang sợ Đóng thử cái
Google trước khi nồi cháy hết à
nó vẫn kịp đóng Noel trước khi lời ở
chạy hết
Ừ ừ
không thì chơi theo kiểu nối chuỗi đi
làm cái này nó hơi bị nông dân quá mình
sẽ chơi cần nối chuỗi đi
thì mình sẽ có nét riêng ở đây bằng
trả lời ngay
ạ sau đó thì mình có sơ sinh
em ngồi thêm cái đoạn này thôi
anh nói gì này
à à
cái dấu huyền này bị lỗi gì vậy
em muốn chị lấy nhỉ Alo cái đậu xanh à
em tắt đi
Ừ vợ tôi
Ừ cái nhỉ
ừ ừ
Anh Sơn Tinh Nghịch
à à
phone mới
a fool monalisa mất tiền nhưng có vẻ là
nó bị lỗi ở cái dấu huyền
dấu Hiền nó bị ngày là vãi chưởng Hải
Triều full
Ừ ừ
như thế mình sẽ dùng mà rét lên đi sẽ
quên mua nồi
họ Công Tằng Tôn Nữ Phạm Văn Chí Diễn
đàn ở sông bé Út miễn dịch vẫn chị hãy
dùng máy này vậy nó nó bị thừa giấu tiền
ở đây rồi sao lỗi à
à à
mình sẽ có suất sinh
anh sẽ nói thêm mắt cô ấy đóng như ngày
ạ sau đó thì mình mới có Open chèn thêm
mình sẽ ghi đè Hạnh luôn thằng
này chấm HTML sẽ Bằng chính cái chỗ này
cho thoải mãi mấy ông hôm nay ở Bình
luận Hôm nay mày không đi lặng đất
trưởng không ngon
lớp im lặng luận à
giờ nếu mình thêm nhiều cái thêm nhiều
cái kiểu dạng
đại khái thêm một vài cá nữa chẳng hạn
ngay Giả sử Giả sử nhà em nhé
sau khi
bao nhiêu cái từng bao nhiêu cái cậu lời
in a lỗi đây là một cách tương đối thôi
Thực ra hội hội cho tôi dùng nhiều cái
nó sẽ in ra ngay bên cạnh như thế này
những con để làm cái bên cạnh nó bị phức
tạp hơn nó phức tạp hơn mình sẽ phải bắt
theo cái nêm của từng thằng xong rồi in
ra nhưng mà đây là Nếu giả sử Nếu giả sử
mà mỗi thằng đấy lại có nhiều cái thông
báo lỗi thằng anh nó hơi bị trong nó hơi
bị nổi mẩn ý cái này ra tôi nghĩa với
nằm ra nhưng ai ở trên cũng được
ở giao diện hơi xấu nhá chứng nhận à
cả vài vết cả của gic mà đầy dữ liệu lên
cũng như ai nó lỗi cho bé uống xe
thường là người ta không làm nông dân
kia với hai người ta không dùng di làm
tất cả các đồng nông dân ngay nhưng mà
tôi chỉ ở mấy ông về việc từ object biến
thành alen Trong như nào in ra dạng nhà
và Vân đúng ạ ạ ạ
nhờ cái đầu tiên mà ông cần làm thì ông
sẽ phải hay nói đi đây mình sẽ hai ẩn nó
đi nhé
anh không không còn ý là lỗi nữa à
mấy ông mấy ông đánh theo cái lớp này
con đã không theo được đấy ông Hợp pp
ông theo lắm à
em thật sự biên đầy đủ toàn bộ thông tin
thì mình sẽ đẩy lên được kha khá nhiều
đồ ngoại
Ừ để anh từ khá nhiều đây để anh City
này Chết này
công ty
a string
bộ phim bắt buộc phải điện 20 apr bắt
buộc không được gì chấm ở đây không
sẽ đi chích
chú ý thì stream
ờ ờ
Ừ nếu có một bể chống tiếp à
à à
Ừ nhưng mà thôi cứ để cho nó có thể từ
trống đây đi
I know này bồ tất cả có được phép về
chồng nhá Ừ
I mean xe Limousine này
là là nếu nếu mà ông kiểm tra theo kiểu
là nếu mà có minh thì phải có mắt và
ngược lại rất là hay đấy tôi sẽ cho mấy
ông xem cái đấy Vậy tôi cho em quen được
ladesh I
Ừ ừ thức amin không cần có mắc nhưng mà
nếu mà
dụ cho mèo hoang đã đây có request ít
đấy
He has equal nghĩa là nếu mà còn nếu mà
có cái này bất không phải có cái kia hai
a
mansory nó không sẽ number
số này có thể chống này
cho từng Minh
em ở nhà
ăn thịt qua các tiểu thư à
Ý là mình sẽ có Di Qua with ngay
ở Sao Đỏ thì mình sẽ là mắt Sorry chẳng
ạ sang hạ thế và ngược lại là nếu mà có
mất Sorry mình sẽ bắt buộc phải có Min
sẽ nặn ra sự nhiều nhất là sự thế thậm
chí ở mình sẽ thêm những cái điều kiện
gì nữa điều kiện là mình sẽ
nào có đầy có cái gì à Mimax rồi
My là bao nhiêu mắt có bao nhiêu ạ
I say
schmelzer đó
anh Mr dam o
a National League
em xem nhá gửi
chú ý thì xx I
thì bắt buộc nó phải lớn hơn lớn hơn cái
thằng Bin đã trả hạ thế và ngược lại nó
có nhỏ hơn tôi đang tra lại xem cái nhỏ
hơn ở gì
ừ ừ
à à
jean-marie kiểu Nga nghĩa là nếu mà có
thì không được phép lớn hơn
từ nhỏ hơn gì gì đó
nếu mà một người mà mới chẳng nhìn cái
đống này quá tải nhưng mà cái này là gần
như là cái nâng ca mà Mấy ông về sau thể
tham khảo sau nếu không hiểu được một
phần là số 8 rồi
cốt là mấy ông xem trực tiếp xem một
Suneo xử lý bài toán như thế nào
anh và tôi kèm theo đó tôi sẽ giải thích
cho một vài cái tôi đang làm cái gì
Nhưng mà thực sự thì để mà hiểu hết hay
để nhớ hết thì cần nhớ là không có
chuyện nhớ còn này hiểu được phần nào
thì tốt được phần đấy Cho bé uống thôi à
đó là sử ở đây tôi cho là 100 này mà tôi
để đây trống thì tôi thử thôi thử ấn led
mình không sẽ thấy nó có lỗi như thế nào
sẽ lỗi ở đây nó sẽ trả về lỗi là đây
ở đầu tiên là Min phải nhỏ hơn mắt này
khi mở tiếp theo là mắc phải điền khi mà
Min có tồn tại lại ra hai cái mép Nhờ
đưa nhau trong trường hợp này thì vẫn có
thể là là
gì mà không đến nỗi là mình bắt buộc
phải điền mấy cái này nhưng mình vẫn
phải kiểm tra là Min khu vực ngõ nhỏ nó
cho nó không được lớn mắc mạng nghe vô
lý
a web với Diego Việt Nam có ổn không ạ
Không biết trả lời rồi Như nào thì tôi
không làm cái này thì
em xem chi cốc tự kiểm chứng ở cái tuyển
dụng các thử thôi không rõ lắm
à quên Suri này quần xi sari thì con xin
hình như tôi bảo đứng trước và mình sẽ
nằm trong cái mảnh danh sách của thằng à
à à
i i i i
a red blue Tất cả cavalo à
anh em lấy tất cả Peru này
danh sách tài sản nằm trong ngày sẽ đi
qua được bắt buộc phải điền nằm music
làm hướng dẫn sáng này ok không cần phải
phiêu bạt ở đây nữa à Vì kiểu gì cũng
phải nằm trong danh sách này rồi nó
không sống được gì
cho Bơ applicant
Ừ cái này không phải đi hà nội bộ
mà nó số Chắc chắn rồi chia số này bắt
buộc phải lớn mình sẽ có thể lớn hơn nữa
anh không nhận mình sẽ là nhìn
chị sẽ là không amin là một trưởng hạt
kín rất là như thế
ý nghĩa là nhỏ nhất ở đâu Cái này tôi
nhớ là sai được
Nhìn thì nhở tôi nhớ là có
Hình như có mì đấy có đại khó Min có mắt
mà
I mean lửa 5 Eric thì nó sẽ cậu bằng một
ai ok ừ
a Tablet này
I started có thể để chống nó kệ bếp nó
sẽ
thì nó sẽ đương nhiên nó sẽ nhỏ hơn mình
sẽ phải dùng cái hàm này là before
before là phải Lớn hơn nhỏ trước trước
với cái BPhone
Vì sao phải cạnh em biết mà
A và ngược lại nếu bạn em biết thì sẽ
anh em tôi đúng không ạ
ở lại là xong
em có dạy gian sweep không ạ
Tôi đang dạy ra suýt đấy thôi hôm dậy
chuyên thôi mà Có vậy mà hai thồ hay thổ
là bắt buộc phải điền này Trinh này và
anh không được phép ngắn quá nó kéo dài
quá được là minmax các thứ thuế Min sẽ
ra nhiều không mi mà không body
a mắt thì sẽ là kiểu 255 phải ạ thường
mặc định là như thế
Smart chắc cũng thế lát này như thế này
và slot thì còn phải thêm một cái đỡ là
kiểm tra là không được phép tồn tại
trong cái trong cái kiểu trong tao bây
rồi không ạ thì mình sẽ ở đây mình à
kiểm tra là unique nó duy nhất
định sẽ thêm cái Unikey ở đây nữa
cho MiMax này này à
chị Thu unit không ạ nick mình sẽ gọi
đến boss như thế này lát
Thế là xong
chất thì unique này
anh sẽ gọi Thay bồ mà mặc định là có lum
có lùn sẽ nếu mà không Điền có luôn sẽ
chính là tên của cái cái này luôn Nó sẽ
là cột sẽ cospak đấy à
đối đấy
Có thể bấm thử thì mày không sẽ xảy ra
ấn thử bây giờ nó sẽ báo những cái lỗi
gì
a language bắt buộc phải điền ông ạ điện
language này ấn lại này
vì vậy lỗi à Pin sorry
a mansory lại đây bởi vì đang điện mình
Sorry nên nó báo lỗi là nó một phải nhỏ
hơn mắt
Ừ thì sao
là
cho tôi bảo tôi không bắt buộc phải điền
mắt đúng ạ khi chỉ cần điền mi được Giả
sử nhiều nơi rồi mới bảo là là lương tối
thiểu là 12 triệu chẳng hạn nhưng không
hề nói là mắc là bao nhiêu nghĩa là mắc
có nghỉ để trống không ạ nhưng bây giờ
nếu mà dùng cái này nếu đang bị cảnh báo
Mấy ông vừa thấy cảnh báo là Min đang đi
đan kiểu dặn là đang không được phép nhỏ
hơn mắt mà mắc đánh trống Thằng em được
báo lỗi giờ trong trường hợp này thì
mình sẽ phải sử lý nha nghĩa là mình sẽ
có khái niệm là ở đây nó có cái rất là
hay nó có cái hàm đó là khi mà tồn tại
khi thảo điều kiện như nào đó thì mới
bắt được xử lý tiếp
sẽ có ra
ờ ờ
áo kiểu xx được ít theo ý hiểu nếu trong
trường hợp nào thì mình sẽ xử lý trường
hợp nào thì kệ bỏ quay
Cho tôi xem nhé
em
xem tham là Ừ từ lúc ấy
ý nghĩa là cái vấn đề chiều cao trách
của em nó vấn đề thôi
theo
chị đã ít
đầu kiểm tra
cho tôi quên chứ rồi
Chú ý bảo
tồn tại
ô tô i10 đang ngồi mò này
nay
mấy ông muốn làm Du
xịn thì mình sẽ phải làm nhé vì trơn
azitro nhé
bạn chất nó làm ảnh mà sẽ ghi Tôn nó nhá
Hai đứa nhọn nhưng mà vô duyên minmax
này ra xử với wimax này tổng nó ra chỗ
khác ở đây này chị sẽ có glu
anh bằng nghe chọn
cô gái ngạc à
ở đây mình sẽ với trong trường hợp là nó
là Mị Như Lai
Ừ vậy thì đại tướng sẽ có hại trước hai
cái
ê vê kết hoa giả nghệ tỷ lệ xóa cho nó
sẽ có trước 2 ngày nay cháu ạ
ờ ờ
ạ sau đó thì vậy với ít
các em à không trống cái thằng à
Ừ Cái Móng chuyển lên đấy thì ông sẽ gọi
được đo rít kiểu ngày Nếu mà không chấm
rằng mắt
bộ phim hình sex chuyển thêm một cái nữa
vào trong tháng ngày
truyền thêm vào đó là thì thời đại và
hôm nay
ở đó
đã truyền thêm màu xanh mày
ở đây mạng mà truyền thêm ở trong mạng
tiếp theo
ở trên thế 8
sẽ
áo vest nam Min
anh
xóa ai đi thôi
nhà nó
hơi mất công đúng không ạ
Ừ
anh Nghĩa đoạn này nó sẽ xử lý ra là nếu
đây trên này vẫn như bình thường nha ạ
nhưng mà trong trường hợp này mình phải
tách ra một tí Nếu mà có có mắt thì mình
sẽ mới chèn thêm cái đoạn là phải nhỏ
hơn mắt
anh còn không thì chỉ cần như thế này đủ
rồi mà ngược lại thế nếu có Min thì mình
sẽ cái mắt này phải lớn hơn Min cái
ở lại sẽ không bị lỗi gì nữa
nữa ngoại thành công này ok chưa ạ
ở Facebook bạc đúng không làm cẩn thận
nha Về sau mấy ông sang có thắc mắc gì
Ok Bây giờ mình
ạ Bây giờ mình có toàn bộ thông tin này
rồi
chị Insert vào thôi mình xin sách những
cái gì thì hôm trước tao bảo là mình có
thể là mình à
Ừ mình mới lấy cái
a Company này mình sẽ lấy Company này ở
mình Insert vào trong cuộc mini trước tỷ
lệ Company ID không ạ Đấy
nhưng mà khi mà anh xuất vào thì
Ừ thì có 2 cách để mà anh xuất một là
ông đi xuất thẳng ở đó là chẳng hỏi gì
chẳng hỏi gì kiểu Thằng đấy là công ty
Thực sự là địa chỉ nó đang ở đâu có văn
không phải biết là như thế còn nếu mà
Mấy ông muốn kiểu
Chị chuẩn chỉ hơn là đã sẽ hiển thị ở
cái phom là sở là người dùng vừa nhập
nhập công ty t là kiểu
FPT thì chẳng hạn nhập PT vào nhưng mà
kiểm tra thông báo tay mình chưa có ghé
VT mình sẽ phải hiển thị ra cái form
để cho người dùng nhập thêm địa chỉ của
FPT là gì Logo dì Vân trước khi mà ấn
xăm mi Phát nữa để mà nhập nhập vào kiểu
như thế kiểu như thế thì tôi nghĩ cách
làm ở đây thì nó sẽ kiểu hơi bị Hơi bị
như thế này một tí đó là
ý là khi mà người dùng Điền xong rồi
dùng bạn quét này ông có thể bắt ông lại
bắt sự kiện ông này bác sự kiện là flash
ngay ông sẽ thì chị một cái mô đồ đây để
mà thêm nhanh một cái Company thay vì
nhảy Sang trang khác Xong rồi điền xong
cái thêm nhanh còn phải đi xong rồi clip
Xong rồi xong rồi
ẩn cái mô đồ đi so and class đấy phản
lại kiểm tra lại xem Company rồi đã được
thêm vào tới bay chưa Nếu mà được thì em
rồi thì mình mới điều hướng sang để mà
thêm cách làm nó sẽ là như thế còn sự
rất là 2a
cho nó hiểu gì không ạ
em gửi tôi không
anh không hiểu Kệ nha à
Anh tắt máy
ở giai đoạn này chuẩn nên mình nên đặt
tên là những cái hạn những cái hàng này
cho nó rộng kéo hàm kiểu như này cho dễ
gọi E
Mấy ông hoàn toàn thêm nhiều cái đu nữa
nha
xem thêm tất Nhiệm vụ đã ở đây được thôi
chỉ đăng ký dụng cho ông ấy không biết
được và có thư viện và Ebay thôi à
mà kiểm tra xe Company tồn tại không này
chỉ trả về có không thôi nó đơn giản Sau
đó mình sẽ lại làm lại làm tiếp điểm Nếu
mà chưa có thì mình sẽ hiện nghĩa với
mua đồ còn có rồi thì mình sẽ bị for
thẳng luôn thì tôi sẽ đây tôi sẽ tạo nên
cái phương trình có đề kiểm tra Thằng
đấy là mình sẽ tạo một phong trình đây
đội cái giấc chạy xong thì mình mới làm
gì đó
rắc nhé
Tắt bớt ở ngoài này Xóa hết rồi đi này
thì sẽ gọi đến hàng router này
Ô kìa ai
giống giống hệt cái Smart này để trách
mình sẽ có làm cái là company
phụ trách chụp ảnh
đó thì tên company
đây sẽ là a Company check Soạn thế về
kiểm tra xem tô tải chưa Thôi tôi đơn
giản
rất đơn giản nghe nó hơi say say nhớ đỡ
giận thật à
Xin chào tạm biệt check ở đây mình sẽ
check lên em ạ
phụ
trách hội được là sửa vào nếu vì sao
không chết thì chả liên lạc đặt tên là
trách gì đấy nha
rồi đây mình sẽ có cái hàm
truyền lên là
à à
mềm ta chẳng cần quét ở đây nữa vì bạn
chất ở với mình lấy cổ phần in em ở đây
này sẽ đô la công ty nên đây luôn tệ Đô
la công ty nêm ai kiểm tra và nếu nó
giống hệt không ạ Như nay mình mình chỉ
trở về chua phone thôi chẳng ạ Giả sử ra
xử thế
là xử thế thì không trả về vi sinh nữa
mình chả về kiểu đơn giản đi là kẹo mút
lên em phải trả về bowling thì tôi có
thể là đội đề axit kiểm tra tồn tại
không
hả mày sẽ trào với bao lần này tôi vứt
cả hai Twitter thẳng về đây luôn Xóa Hay
đi này là đây mình sẽ trả về vulan có
đúng sai chua thôi rất đơn giản à
Ừ thì bên này mình sẽ chuyên mình sẽ
truyền đây là mình sẽ gọi đến api này
chấm
a Company chấm check ngoại sau đó mình
sẽ truyền lên cái
thì mình sẽ gạch chéo
gì nữa mình sẽ chuyển là
open in nó sẽ là đô la
sẽ Lách qua bên nhà ở
router để tên web Ừ đúng rồi tôi vẫn
biết mà chẳng bao tách riêng như này cho
tường minh mày không hiểu à Cái này file
này về sau mình gọi kia chung ở rất
nhiều nơi
nói như thế
ngày inspo này con số
in ra cái con nó mới không xem nhé
bác sĩ trả về chùa thôn thôi à ở đây tôi
sẽ là trách company
Anh
check in this cũng được Nếu mày không
muốn đặt tên nó rõ ra à
này à
cười đó là bởi vì cái này nó không
truyền vào trong cái cái này thì ra
thằng này đang bị báo lỗi
tôi tất nhiên họ chấm Cái này không bắt
buộc phải điện cũng được không sao không
sao khẳng định Mỹ sẽ phải điền vào rồi
Ừ ừ
đúng nhỉ hỏi chấm như hỏi chấm 1 đêm
đúng à
hình ảnh
I speak này Network này à
mở
ra sổ cho điện một cái tên Company xuất
sản không tồn tại đúng không ạ quét này
thì nó sẽ gọi đến
à à bắt buộc phải điền nó huyết anh ạ
anh bấm viết này
Ừ thì thì nó sẽ gọi đến A anh đi phải xã
lý file này
anh ạ
stock company đúng rồi
3.3 lu xài
khi bị thiếu thiếu tiền chứ ạ
nào về poland Ừ vậy nè Ở đây đang không
không không hay lắm à
Em có muốn đang muốn làm thế này cho đơn
giản không cần phải trả vé rất xa dụng
gì cả
ở những lại không được rồi
Ừ nếu mà thế thì à
à à
khi lại copy các loại này làm nhé
chị sẽ đây là
à à
các chuyên đề là company
thẳng router luôn thắng tôi luôn
bắt đầu từ ngày nay
truyền lên nó ghét bảo vệ sinh không in
không truyền data gì nữa
rồi Sắp xít thì mình sẽ làm gì đó đây
alo mình sẽ làm gì đó đây cho nặng thế
Anh không cứ mặc định ở khứ sắp xếp đi
mình
sẽ install đây cho béo nhé
công ty không tồn tại đúng không
Khi Chọn đầu ích này
à Quên à
thì nó sẽ
là ờ ờ
À mà tôi định làm là nó sẽ luôn trả về
đúng
ừ ừ
axit đ Ê
pete ơn Sis
soi trả về cả data và cái biến trách này
như thế này
anh ở đây mình sẽ
Em in ra cải cách
ừ ừ
ở Iran cảnh sát ở trong
ở đoạn này hơi bị lằng nhằng một tí nữa
không nhớ là truyền cái bình trách vào
đây nhá
lại cho người ta tay đúng không Sắp xít
luôn là chua nhá và nó sẽ trả về ở trong
cái này như thế này là tạo ở trong nó
nữa
à à
khi DC này không có này chọn này
bí quyết này
khi đó nó sẽ trả về là không có là phone
hoặc trở về phone Em thấy không nó ra
phone sự tôi chọn cái triệu rúp này ấn
vào này nó sẽ trả về nó đã tạo là Chu
Tôi đang làm chưa Cái cái Company thì có
ngoại Thì bây giờ mình sẽ bắt trường hợp
ít đi bar chấm
xe Tata
Nếu mà đúng thì mình sẽ làm gì nếu đúng
như ta là mình sẽ sắp ít Tom thôi mình
sẽ kiểu à
thì mình sẽ điều hướng
A Gọi nhà
và mình sắp lý cái form mày cần như thế
bị ngược đãi mình sẽ check thì không Tôi
đi trước nhỉ
thứ Ba đến
I like this song
Nghe nhạc chế của mini trước
ừ ừ
Ừ hình như thằng pha đến này nó có cái
là befo before sắp đi đấy à đấy Ở tra
nhé
sắp với phom lên mình sẽ làm được gì nhớ
có trả lại đi
phe
rồi
chỉ biết đọc thư viện nó không
ờ ờ
mà đến này
thứ ba lít rồi
ờ ờ
a
map diffuse
prix thành Focus
anh sex Việt Phố
Anh check for
iPad format
ở nhà có thế
Ừ hình như là có phô mai buổi sáng ý
ừ ừ
khi nuôi con
trước khi mà cái sắp ít này hay đồ rồi
Thế thì mình sẽ phải Tấm cái mình sẽ đẩy
cái này lên trước này trách này xong rồi
chết xong thì mình sẽ sắp from mình sẽ
gọi cái hãng Hàn này
Ừ mà mày Tôi sẽ đặt tên nó chết Company
nha tên Hà này nó là tống hết nó trong
ngày như thế này
Ý là mình sẽ là
Em sắp mít Tom chẳng hạn là khi mà
sau khi mà có rồi thì mình sẽ sắp it
from này còn nếu không em này thì mình
sẽ làm gì mình sẽ thì ra một cái mua đồ
Tôi chẳng cần phải gọi này nó Tết là
ngày mà nó là bom vết ố
cốt nữa
là mình cơ mặc định là mình cư
em kiểm tra Company chẳng hạn Đông ạ số
Điền sang Company thì mình sẽ kiểm tra
xem có money tồn tại không Xong rồi nếu
có tồn tại rồi thì mình sẽ sắp đi cái
for Mày lên rồi kiểm tra một con nữa
còn không Mình sẽ chỉ định với mua đồ
không ạ Mua đồ đây tôi lại
tôi dùng tới sẽ dùng Model của thằng
Wechat mì ăn liền à
ở
đây à
ra mà mua đồ đấy mình bạn chất mình sẽ
tạo trước một sẵn một cái mô đồ
để mà điền các từ thứ này nó sẽ tạo
trước sáng để mua đồ như thế này
Em
có mua đồ ở đây ở đây là mua đồ
Company em ạ
sau đó thì
read Company và sự thế
ờ ờ
ở đây trong này mình sẽ có một cái foam
À hôm để thêm Company đấy
là mình sẽ nhảy đến Kyoto là
Rồi cái sau ngày mất rồi tính sau mình
sẽ là Company chấm press rằng ạ
em ở đâu Story lưu lại mà to này
tự nhiên mới thốt thì sẽ là
sau đó thì ở đây mình có xe SH Ý
Company name từ vừa nãy mình Điền thì sẽ
điền xuống dưới này cái thứ nhất
Tôi sẽ copy ở đây tôi mượn nó copy đã
nhá
ở vòng đeo đi
phút mình sẽ là sửa glycyrrhiza chẳng
cách xử thế thì vừa điền cái thằng nêm
game à Nếu nó muốn sửa lại Nó phải tắt
cái tắt cái mua đồ đi nó điện lại tên
sau đây mặc định mình sẽ cho nhé là
còn em cho nó này là Company này
e-money
à à
anh ở nhà
thôi em mình còn gì nữa nha mình sẽ cho
điện Express rồi các thứ thứ
bây giờ có thể điện nhiều hơn đấy mình
sẽ điền cả Glass Z2 này this citys chẳng
hạn thế
Everest này à
à À quên đã quên đấy phải kiểu class là
nó
ừ ừ
The Flash
mà mong con trâu
anh bỏ đi bỏ đi Không cần Không phải lúc
nào mày cũng lên cần ô mai đi về
ver2
for cloud ngay nó sẽ đẹp hơn à
ở
đó như này
à à
I S2
HD hay
dùng Ngoài đẹp hơn tiếp theo mình sẽ có
số mệnh sẽ có đi chút và City nhưng mà
thì nó sẽ điện sẵn hộ nó sẽ kiểu
district theo cái mình vừa nãy chọn ngày
không hiểu rồi
này Tí nó sẽ điền sẵn hộ nghĩa là ba cái
có thể nhìn rõ nhé kompany này City đi
chít chính là cái mà vừa nãy mình điện ở
trên Nhưng mà nhưng mà ở cái này mình
vẫn thể cho chọn lại đông ạ Em vẫn Thôi
trả lại nhé
Ừ dạo này tí đang nhàng ấy gửi tí mình
sẽ phải loát thêm mà trong hàng này nữa
chị xem đấy
còn gì nhỉ
Ừ tôi cứ tạm tạm thế đã để hiển thị
trong mấy cũng dễ hình dung nhé
I
am in store notify thoát bớt đó ngoài đi
nhiều quá nhiều quá Mình sẽ có là chị sẽ
có lúc này sẽ có open
open is a
đây mình store này lại có Company này
ai ngờ mình chưa tạo cái
ô tô chưa tạo cái
ở ngoài chế tạo bền amin the company's
Ừ thôi Nghĩa dùng tạm ở bên
Ừ cái này cho đi cái này chơi đi
à à
có phải trang này
Vì vậy tôi xem thử điện một con vật lý
không tồn tại trong đó không xem à
bài viết này
mua đồ ấy nhỉ quên bây giờ Làm thế nào
để Wind em phải được cái mua đồ Này ông
sẽ chỉ đơn giản là ông gọi đến nhá ông
gọi đến Hàn để mình in chữ câu nó ra
thôi
Có cái khái niệm nói chi câu
ờ ờ
một đơn chat xem tivi Sau chọn
mình sẽ gọi đến ở đây như thế này sẽ là
mua đồ company
u
sầu tím bị ra tại cho anh em
khi chọn này
ở
đó nó bị lâm cái phone xin nào thì nó
trong lại bị lại cả ngu si nhỉ
vợ chồng như thế này mà nghỉ tại sao nó
bị lệch kiểu đấy nhỉ Mua đồ hay thồ các
thứ thứ
ý đổi lịch chung kết thật sự à
có mất Xảy ra này
ngày để đó flash class ở đây flash ở Ừ
mai đi
Anh chưa về bên phải
anh ạ
à còn gì cần chỉnh nha À môi bây giờ mày
không thấy hiển thị ra này rồi không ạ Ừ
chị sẽ còn nút ở bên phải
thì mình sẽ có hai nút ở đây một nút
thắt một nút được lâu rồi ạ Ông làm cái
gì ông đừng có làm cái nút close nó rõ
quá bấm sử lúc lâu đấy à
à à
sắp ít ở đây họ được
ừ ừ
a crash chẳng hạn ở
ở đâu xem nhá xem nhé Đây
Ê bà thấy Company này nó sẽ phải tự động
tự động này
Zalo sẽ Bằng chính cái Đôla
a City và đi xuyên đảm sẽ thế
a City đấy
Ừ thì nó sẽ tự động Điền không ạ
đợi tâm tí Đợi tôi tí
Ừ nhưng mà mình phải loát cái City mình
sẽ phải loát cái toàn bộ City vào trong
thằng này được thì nhé mình ngoan lấp
đầy vào trong tháng này
sẽ back2black City hen vào trong này
fan thêm cả Anh ở trong phòng à
City như này nữa Chúc em và cả hai này
ừ ừ
Xem tiếp
ờ ờ
sex hay đi chi tiết
thứ ngày
cả ngày hoặc thằng kia
cả ngày hoặc thằng City
ở trên thì mình sẽ loát
sữa nutty chỉ đoán chắc là mình sẽ xóa
cái thằng đi trí cũ
à à
thì mình sẽ truyền đo Zip vào trong như
thế này Tại sao bởi vì à Mình muốn gọi
đây là thằng Mít cho anh ạ
đây sẽ có rít
ừ ừ
áo giáp đi
ngầm Nga
giết giáp hồi trưa rất nhiều người Nhầm
cái gì che đậy sát này gọi đến hàng hả
Anh nói thằng con sẽ chất của nó
a file con sẽ thích
thế này
sau khi tờ hải file gì đó
có ai ngờ lấy thằng đầu tiên thì à
ờ ờ file splitter
a recovery
ờ ờ option IS selected
à à
anh chúc mình nhớ mình làm như thế nào
nhỉ
thằng đầu tiên thôi thì phải một lấy hết
thằng toàn bộ tất cả thằng đấy Tối nghĩa
không nên dùng file đâu à mà nên dùng à
a monster dùng hàm gì nhỉ
ừ ừ
I breathe
trò chuyện này có số nhiều số ít đây nhá
ông ông ông à
là một trong số nhiều thì nó khác nhé
về Minecraft
à à
hai chân phát
anh Hải sẽ
một tí với sao gì à
Ờ Ờ tôi đang muốn làm là
A gọi trung vào cái hành loa ĐT này
nhưng mà đây nó có một bê giả sự Giả sử
nhé mình à Mình thoát ra mình mình chọn
lại City ở đây thì cái thằng Model kia
thì nó Anh
em mua đồ vừa rồi nó bị ảnh hưởng thì kệ
kệ nó nhưng mà Nếu giả sử mà mình chọn
cái mô đồ đấy nó ra bên này nó bị tác
động heo cái năng selec chết là nó bị
tác động theo nó không đúng không Đúng
nói thích lắm ở ngoài đóng bộ đen hết
nhưng mà tôi đang
trẻ em hay bị đau đầu với nạn này
Ừ dạo này đang lên xử lý nhé nhé
I made it này
Ta không đúng lắm ở phía bây giờ mình sẽ
bắt heo thằng mình phải biết được là
thằng thằng City mình đang chọn là cái
thằng ở ở ngoài hai thằng mua đồ
nếu thằng nếu thằng ngoài này thì mình
mới lót hài không ạ Còn thằng mua đồ thì
mình phải giữ nguyên hàng ngày
không mình xóa sử cái người dùng đã chọn
thì nó không nó sai ờ
cách này nó bị hơn này
vẫn là sẽ lách bị chết đúng không Tôi sẽ
đặt tên cho nó Ai đi a nó thế hợp lý ai
đi nó là
a slack
cái sân nhà bạn ạ
anh
điền vào Ok Ok bạn ở dưới này tôi cũng
sẽ có một cái
ở dưới này
Ừ tôi sẽ có class này đúng không Hay là
cùng chung một class ok rồi nè sau đó
thì
anh ở đây khi mà mình
Ừ mình loạt này đúng không Mình gọi jit
mình sẽ gọi lên parent
anh sẽ gọi thằng cha à
snack location ngay nó sẽ gọi Hoàng Sa
nó đây sẽ sẽ à Holland vợ từ Balan mình
sẽ gọi thằng con
có gì này
A
và từ ba lần này mình sẽ gọi đến thằng
con nít để mà em Ti nó anh không xem nhé
Ở đây mưa nà
mỗi ngày chúng các class để mình thêm
cho nó là select live
à à
Anh đang nhận quá thường là làm gì Huy
đó mới bị kiểu ngay làm làm cái khác
không thử không bao giờ bị trường hợp
của OSI nha à
ạ Bây giờ tôi sẽ gọi Talent gọi đến
thằng say như này sẽ gọi cậu nhà nha
Thảo lần này
A gọi childen là celastrus mà lần này sẽ
gọi thực flash
nó xong rồi xóa nó đi đó thì đi không
này sẽ xóa đi này một thêm mới location
ok rồi này sau đó thì chữ get này hết
rồi này sau đó thì thằng ngày
à à
liệu thêm vào
Nghe có vẻ đúng rồi đúng ấy chạy thử nhé
Vãi xuống đi
à
à ngoài đúng rồi mặc định lúc đầu không
có Ward dist a
position đây là không bị báo lỗi vì
không
em không có chuyện Thằng cha mà nếu
không cho làm cha vào thì mình sẽ hiểu
mặc định thằng cha là cái gì đó đi
từ đầu nó đang là dẫn đi mình không ép
mà không giá trị gì cả ít
a parent
ừ ừ
Vì sao
là thằng đi trước kia là ngon thì sẽ
tưởng có trách này
à à
anh em như thế này không thì mặc định sẽ
là cái thằng đầu tiên là thằng đô la
ừ ừ
à à
cha mẹ mày
ở đây mình sẽ có of Zack
ở Hàn
Ừ ok
Ừ Ok Ok
Thảo lên đã chống nhiều father ở đây
chấm thì
trong thì mình sẽ gọi đền A thằng
tự như tôi làm xử lý và toàn nó phức tạp
hơn nhiều rồi
dân ca nhạc
ừ ừ
tiên đoạn này mình cần bu toàn bộ đi
chết trước chắc chắn rồi rồi này đúng
không đi chích mà mình sẽ dựa theo chính
cái city lúc đầu mình chọn này đúng
không ạ
city lúc đầu mình chọn là cái select
City này không ạ Thế là mình sẽ truyền
Alex City ở trong này
cô gái tự nhiên tôi làm mẹ khó lên ta sẽ
chuẩn Surf City trong ngày xong à
ờ ờ
a City trong ngày thơ thứ ngoại à
ở đoạn này thì ta vui Tôi đoán anh bị
thừa quá sẽ gọi Tha Lần có nó như thế
này à
chết đi này rồi Gì nhỉ anh Helen này nó
sẽ gọi đến thằng con thấy toàn bộ ấp
chân sẽ tất Đúng rồi này
a tiếp theo
Anh nói thằng này nó sẽ gọi đến hàng
ngày để chèn thêm dữ liệu vào
Ừ Ok có về đồ đấy chạy đi
anh không được thì thôi
tôi tại xong thế này
xin
lỗi à
Vì sao lỗi nhỉ
có size
lỗi
ô nhiễm bị xóa trên này thiếu một cái
đóng gì đó nó sẽ bị lỗi đấy
file này
I Penny
Ừ đúng mà
trò chuyện Alpha
à à
khi sex
Anh có lỗi gì nhỉ
không biết lỗi như nào Mày không có thể
khi đóng lại này không thử tại lại xem
vào không
ờ ờ
đề tài
à à
anh hỏi thử
bí ẩn này đi
em bị lỗi
xin lỗi này nhờ do cái file đường dẫn
này có vấn đề
ờ ờ
khi solo ạ
có mấy cái này mày cái logo mà
Ừ thì tôi
tìm kiếm micro rồi Tắt hết đi nhé không
nói ngay
xin lỗi nhỉ à
I sleep
lỗi lỗi tại wi-fi này có vấn đề location
phát ở đây có vấn đề
a sport ở đây trở về nó bị gần đây à à
từ hôm trước vừa nãy vừa nổi nghỉ tại
sao bây giờ lại bị chết cái này
à À đây edifier rồi khác ở đây đang có
vấn đề chết này nó bị lỗi Ok Xem ba lần
trước đã
i-talents Thằng này Sao không lấy được
anh sex tất
em không ra được có mày nghỉ
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
em là thằng này
sữa rửa mặt
I haven't I
anh Helen gọi đến find
à à
các file trên sex
mô hình
thì nó đang là
a hand of Fate of her's
anh em phẩm
anh ở đây thì phải gọi kiểu này không
hơn nếu parent có 1 chữ s thì tôi nhớ
mầm như là chỉ gọi một cấp rồi vậy
a3200is thì gọi bao nhiêu cấp được mới
gọi được đến chuẩn thằng cha
ở đó đây đây đây đây rồi
khi phát ra cho đội ok ok
có gj status
ngồi mò thì có li a
anh hơn pha ngay
đó ra được rồi nha Sau đó thì à
xe chạy được
ở Hồ Chí minhbình Tân Nha đổi hẳn thành
phố khác trong mấy ông Ba Đình nhé nóng
gọn flash này
ở Hồ Chí Minh ai rồi à
Ừ ừ
Company gọi đến slack company
Ừ đúng rồi nhỉ
là nếu mà làm kiểu va như thế này thì nó
sẽ không chích cơ Cái thằng
đi đái phải không Nó đang chọn Hà Nội là
nó chưa được cơ dẫn hình chữ chi cầu ở
đây nữa để kích hoạt cái á
cái charice 2a
à à
các bạn đời company
a company's ra rồi
chưa chụp kiểu đấy
cả ngày cũng thế này
à À thằng đi chết này thì sẽ như thế nào
nhỉ Thằng đấy chuyện này bản chất là nó
chưa được lót
em chưa được lót này toàn bộ đi chích
cái đi chít của thằng
à à
trước đã
a What time city này gọi đến a a
những hình ảnh
ở
ngoài salad beat
a Excellent location nhất à
à à
thì mình sẽ gọi thằng cha này
trò chuyện lạ đó thì tại sao có web đây
phải cầm thằng warchief của cái thằng
City mình đang chọn trước đã
rồi mới à
cho snack xà lách nó
các bạn vất vả vãi làm tivi lại với Bảo
vãi tôi bắt đầu hơi bị nản
34 buổi rồi chưa xong cái đoạn clip chỉ
vì jq dinh dưỡng đậu xanh
ở Cầu Giấy nhá nick này
cách chữa trị cơ Này thằng này vẫn đây
rồi anh giờ đây có vẻ là
em chưa được trí cho
Em hãy chưa được lót
ừ ừ
em ngồi cư tạo Ẩn Hoài đã tính này sau
ngày còn chưa lên được này
à à
cô gái mới dậy
khi chọn đấy ghét này
anh có ok chưa
Tại sao lại đưa ra rồi
những điệu nhảy hay ra rồi đi
nó bắt sự kiện nên thành ra là nó vào
đây luôn à Xong rồi thì nó chọn luôn ạ ạ
xịt phết đấy Không cần bác này nữa ngon
thì chỉ cần gọi cậu ngay sau trên con
nữa là xong OK OK rồi đấy
Anh vừa mới kêu Gái lập tức được ngay
cái lại phải gái rồi à
khi chọn Hà Nội này
ở trận Cầu Giấy này bấm này
không phải được đậu xanh Hình như là cái
thằng này nó bắt sau
nhà hàng ngày à
Ê thằng lót
áo lót này nó chưa kịp chạy Xong thì
thằng này đã gọi nên thành ra là ở đâu
Ừ đúng rồi nên là nó hài Chưa được gọi
anh thấy đi tôi khi mà thằng này đổ lót
xong hết rồi Như này thì à
thì sẽ cần phải cậu
em chọn lại cái cũ Đợi tí hay bị xóa rồi
này MT xóa này
a pen a pen tonight
anh có bằng đèn led
ở đây
string chọi dỗ này
Ừ nó đi đây Open Dạo này đi làm gì để mà
tôi sẽ
anh ở ngay đây
Ừ để xem nhé
à à
em vất vả thế à
a disease dài vãi hồi nãy tôi làm Duy
mày không hiểu cảm giác rồi tôi không
Tôi đi hơn 200 lòng hay đang làm gì Lili
Taylor rõ lắm rồi đó thì rõ dài
a mess with một cái gì đó rất là mệt
ở Cầu Giấy này bấm vào này đó hà nội-cầu
giấy quá ngọt sẽ làm mất công nhưng mà
thôi
mỗi Speed nãy ở chị người làm ra special
bắt sự kiện ở các thứ từ học đúng khóc
thật
ở nhà thôi cũng được chọn này
ở trọ lại mất này từ từ à À đúng rồi nó
chỉ cơ trên nó bắt sự kiện không tìm
thấy ở đây
anh không có
I tr
khi sex
à à
đi xe tất cả
không có việc gì khó em ạ Không thấy khó
Ừ được cái này ở đây
em
đổi sách tất vào trong Mai
anh chỉ có mỗi trường hợp mà Lát cái
Xin chào mào lót để mà gọi điện cho
thằng Sơn nick thật nhỉ
Khi ngài gọi trên rồi họ trên
thứ ngày
được
[âm nhạc]
khi sex
a stackblue đây constant
anh alo
sẽ bằng cái này ok rồi này Xóa ID
thế này đây này
giờ nếu mà ít
anh em mình sẽ cho
có thêm có phải thì tự nông dân ngay cơ
à
thằng à x tại
Ừ thì mình sẽ sinh thêm cái
anh sex tất à
à à
thì
tại sao tự nhiên tôi phải làm thêm cái
đoạn khổ sở như thế này của kìa
thì mình sẽ tập nó bây giờ trong trường
hợp nếu mà cái đi chút có bởi vì rõ ràng
Vừa rồi tôi chọn xong tôi vườn đấy là là
chọn bên này Cầu Giấy nên thành ra cái
nên của nó là Cầu Giấy kia tôi chọn xanh
bạn án thì cái cầu giấy không tồn tại
nữa thì ra là không nó không có sẽ chất
trong Mai ngoại không có sân thì đánh em
mặc định phải cái đầu tiên nhưng do nó
đã se Lac tập Ở một cái nước Cầu Giấy ở
chỗ khác rồi hai cái bị lỗi tôi đang
kiểu phải làm cái cậu chạy vòng lặp Kiểm
tra kiểu nhé ai Chắc là đủ
uống vị thuốc làm đau đầu
ừ ừ
ở trọ này cầu giấy nhá báo từ liên nha
Ok này clip này
ở Bắc Từ Liêm đúng không
ở Đà Nẵng ok chưa
nó
[âm nhạc]
dễ
đại đi lên trường nha chọn
rồi bây giờ
chị mấy nhỉ
chọn
cho hai thằng Bình Dương ấy không có nhỉ
anh điên thật ở đỉnh Tĩnh à
chị Loan đấy chứ
Ừ nó bảo mày nè
cuộn vào nó cô huyện à
á nhon nó không có chuẩn
anh giật mình có giờ cột lỗi đậu xanh
rồi
ở quận huyện quận huyện phải trưởng
Ừ
ông không phải lỗi Tôi nghĩ ra cái này
có thể huyện
Kỷ Niệm
Ừ ok là đây
và đấy quá đấy một lỗi là điều lắm đấy
Không biết sửa nhà luôn
ở đây ngoãn bấm này Chương Mỹ không ạ
ở Đà Nẵng Cẩm Lệ Kon Tum đặt đây Hà Nội
vẫn là chống Mỹ chị nào hủy toàn theo
cái cũ mà ngon không
Ừ ông bảo tôi quê ông dọa vào ống sưởi
ông hiểu toàn bộ những gì tôi dậy ông
lên ghế tôi ngồi làm sciglio luôn chứ
không còn là yên tâm đấy làm bà yên tâm
cái học phí khóa sau làm được yên tâm mà
học hết khóa trước là Minute ơn rồi Con
học hết khóa này thành cổ sciglio rồi
chờ đợi đâu rồi quá cho tôi đây thôi
chào hôm nay ở tạm ngừng đây tôi cảm
thấy đâu sẽ Sáng làm mấy con người đau
đầu hơn nha Chúng ta không ai tặng nhưng
ở đây
lắm cuối cả đây để làm gì anh nhỉ
kỹ thuật language để làm gì nhất
chỉ cần gần à
cái hay phết biết được hả Có vấn đề chỗ
nào mình Xóa bớt đi Ví dụ À cái này
không được sử dụng hai cái gì đâu mua sử
dụng đây chắc ạ rất là ổn
Ồ thông báo hộ mình mấy cái biến mình
không dùng
hàm mình dùng và các bạn Xóa bớt đi
ở tại Thái của mày này đau đầu quá
quanh quẩn việc thực hiện người dùng
không ạ Điên Điên Điên Điên các thứ thôi
hiển thị ra cái form để mà điền nốt
không ạ Vẫn chưa xong bữa hôm sau sẽ là
buổi từ từ sẽ làm mỗi tính năng thêm bạn
Nhưng mà thêm này không chính xác không
phải thêm 01 bản phút nữa mà thêm này
mình sẽ thêm rất nhiều bạc không ạ thì
sẽ thêm nghĩa là gần như ở tỉnh nào bến
amin là xong rồi đấy nếu mà nếu mà làm
xong cái tốt này gần như toàn bộ tính
toàn bộ thêm thêm kiểu các thứ thứ là
tương đối xong Ừ thì rồi sau đó thì mình
làm tính năng nha hiển thị bên người
dùng nữa là là gần như là là đã có thể
dùng được rồi béo mình không là đã gần
như trang web có thể chạy được rồi bên
bên ứng viên bên động viên có thể xem
tìm kiếm và đã ổn Ôi tương đối ổn thôi
Họ đương nhiên là mình sẽ nâng cấp thêm
nó là ứng viên hay đang được sivi xong
rồi an ninh duyệt siêu vi van này nữa
sau đó đi hát rồi có thể đăng bài thơ ca
hát rồi đăng bài cũng sẽ ốp đúng với
giao diện bên này để mà sang cho bên
Hazard anh thôi ông ạ Đấy sau đó thì bên
A
anh nói chung mà còn thêm một vài cái
nhỏ nhỏ thôi chắc cũng dễ mà nhớ tạm
thời Thế nên là tôi mới làm chi tiết này
chứ không rảnh ngồi làm chi tiết dưới
này đâu đấy bố mày cũng nhận đau đầu quá
rồi Tại cái gì đây nhá hai tiếng ơi
em làm gì nhé tin hôm nay mình chán lắm
ở quán nửa không hiểu đâu
Xin
chào mấy ông nhé